we need to talk ah like a bab-ee why Tim  why didn't know where we don't even know  him how can we track him he wears a suit  I know it thank you he's like a little  man you carries a briefcase there's no  one knows things that oh I don't know a  little freaky  will you carry lamb-lamb around until  you will do is not about lamb-lamb all  babies are different and each one is  special  he said over the whole house I'm taking  over the house yes you are  trust me one day you're gonna get to  know this little guy mhmmm and you're  gonna love him with all of your heart  just like we do now what Behrens think  is going on I'm doing well all and  what's really going on we have to  convince them that we no no no way no  [Music]  gusting Sabula straight the story is  about cannibalism and burning people  alive yeah no wonder kids are so messed  up  you